oh you can take them off yes
alright Rebecca alright yes Rebecca well
where you from originally where'd you
grow up I mean I grew up in New York I
grew up partly New York and partly in
Paris for like a few years like I've
traveled all over but I grew up on the
Lower East Side and I moved to Brooklyn
for a bit as a foster kids and you know
tell me about shopping um yeah New York
exciting colors and you know really
vibrant it's not honey you know what I
mean you're just you're living your life
a certain way you know like I went to
school and then eventually I dropped out
and I kind of got another party scene
and I tried my hand at modeling you know
I wanted to travel
kinda like Ryan McKinley but then I
realized that I love the city too much
so I what about your family your parents
oh my parents are dead your parents are
dead
yeah they leave that like I was adopted
kind of and then I mostly bounced around
foster homes
people didn't really want me cuz I was
trans it was hard to find like they call
it placement you know what I mean in the
system and as like I get in a lot of
trouble with drugs and you're like they
knew me for that so eventually at 16 I
just kind of like [ __ ] off I guess
so you've been living on the street for
how long sometimes 16 so kind of like
five six years now yeah
so you're I'm 22 22 yeah and where do
you stay right now kind of all over he's
not really from LA I had friends and
Echo parts and staying with them for a
bit and then I like being in East LA
because there's more space like I'm
around Skid Row cuz like it's a great
place to get a bang outfit I got this
this morning from this entirely on the
floor I'm just caught which I love but
like East LA cuz there's more space
that's more expensive and there's kind
of bit more greenery there like I'll
kind of trying like hiking to Pasadena
and like possible someone's like so you
roam around yeah I guess I mean I only
really came to California cuz I want to
go to Big Sur
I really really always want to go to Big
Sur since I was a kid I spent more time
in I'm Florida kind of urgently because
I was on the East Coast and where do you
where do you sleep at night you know
wherever yeah it's it's not really
important to me cause if I'm gonna sleep
on the sleep um I have some utilize
hearing I don't know I don't really care
if I can find a blanket I'm out you know
and what are you doing for money um
sometimes I just like smart sometimes I
do kind of little modeling gigs
sometimes I'd Panhandle you know I just
walk around on his Lee and bum smokes
and fine I don't know um it's not that I
serve myself I want to have fun I don't
want something to get in the way of that
I'm not gonna enslave myself to have fun
I'm young while I'm young you know
interferes I'll get an office temp job
and get fat and Neutra suburbs be great
for the next 500 is my life you know I
was like two good years of fresh young
blood in me you know
and
it's easing holidays get a screen
testing is like a young trans getting
all get typecast I guess there aren't
really roles or anything like that so
that's not how I'm geared then just then
having a lot of fun I have a lot of fun
which I think intimidates a lot of
people what is your drug mmm MDMA I
guess the party wise I mean if I can
afford it
I smoke a lot of cigarettes cigarettes
it's so good buyer do you get hassled on
the street oh if I keep myself kind of
yes and no I don't really talk to a lot
of people on those like specific kept
them you know sure but not really not
how I would have resumed like in New
York you know people just say it like it
is you're having some punch right and
[ __ ] face suddenly fun you know what
I mean yeah rape you got raped here not
like there's a lot of pretense a lot of
CCTV a lot of people like I don't like
you know what I mean so you're gonna use
that to your advantage
I guess the New Yorker in me and just
give me you've been raped before why not
yeah sure
I'm not a victim people get ready
I've even got my legs sink chopped off
after you know and so back to your
family you your parents what happened
your parents house they died they died
before I was born in car crashes only in
them they died before you were running
like Buffalo get everything I don't
really want to that's all right
got it do you have any family siblings
anything I have like sisters you know
what I mean
of like a lot of sisters like
state-to-state I have a lot of family I
have more like a coven I'm ohso of my
coven my family do you ever talk to your
family oh my cousin of course all time
any time I need that kind of you know
what I mean it's there I don't have to
question it it's beyond family you know
family it's good you know and I mean the
American dream you mom and pops and you
know visit the grandparents Christmas
okay all right awesome
I need someone who's there for me when
I'm having to explain to a cop that I'm
on my period and so therefore I can't do
a blood draw where is my vagina okay
let's go to the hospital and you know
what I mean I have my witches my wages
are my family
why would you tell the family I would
ever need do you have any friends
Rebecca yeah you do yeah where did you
meet these friends anywhere just on the
street why not it's not like that you
know people my presumption
I guess I'm wired a little differently I
don't know I travel so I meet people up
down bed no I stayed at the standard
before but the one New York not in
Hawaii no and now they're just these are
really really small miss fixated knew -
[ __ ] - no Molly and I ended up in Queens
under a bridge for four days and you
prefer LA to New York no but I didn't
know that until I came here I really
thought I was gonna like like I
understand the city I guess is just cuz
I'm not like working I'm not like
looking for a script and I'm more of a
model an actress so I'm not immediately
you know
anyways is so family-oriented which I
understand I'm like the studio system is
I felt like an indie like Gregg Araki no
I definitely prefer any work but I love
LA I'm here and it's different
modern LA is different there isn't as
much it like I don't know people seem to
really detest a certain sort of glamour
so people want to be more kind of like
me work but laid-back it's nice yeah
well how do you think living on the
street is has affected you great that
muscles now um I can think on my feet
more and I'm Way more resourceful than I
ever thought I could and I don't give
half a [ __ ] which I never thought was
ever gonna happen again ever thought I'd
love myself
they just think we got eyes like [ __ ]
yeah hey [ __ ] together grabbing things
literally like off that like I literally
just grabbed this lipstick and this week
I saw this wig literally on a pile of
trash clothes and I was just like
intercept you the person living in the
time to intercept let me have a knife
understand the theorists or severe
crimes we can run [ __ ] and little
aliens may JLo moment so right JLo
impersonator in Reno I [ __ ] love it
because why not
I'm free mm-hmm in a wild I'm free
yeah really African I feel of it I
really really love it I'm not something
the way people want me to stop her like
yeah I get hungry I get free irritated I
want to say grand final and broke okay
but like I'm I'm really not like things
aren't this isn't our former you know
he's a very expansive tab you see I'm so
where do you really like eat what did
what do you do for food or um if I'm
really I give them to that point I'll
sounds like balls just begged somebody
something I'm eating dropping get food
places I don't know it's LA no one
really eats right you should've just
have someone to rest their [ __ ] sweet
creamy yes people left doors and I don't
like again it's something button is that
like it that wasn't about necessity like
I'm not and this is Detroit like the
that there there are things around here
there are resources around here there
people around here and I mean they're
they're they're they're celebrities
around here who you can you check very
nicely for a cigarette is one story I
love I'm at Ottawa agua
on the beach she shoot Adobe magazine
seven five morning and I was like coming
down hard I just gone over rave I ran up
turn my god-wife fuzzy smoke security
I'm like as I love beams nothing moving
are you trying to meet choice nothing
but twist line is very hard to find so
you don't here in Skid Row today for
what
Oh um for um clothes I come to skid row
for clothes and his kid roofer clothes
then I go downtown for cigarettes and
then from there I can expect to meander
around for whatever it is they've
actually I just got lost you know Jimmy
D I know Skid Row clothes downtown
smokes skater out you only a slug them
anyone no one feeling likes you no one
wants to like you you don't know them
they don't know you
good for you grab [ __ ] off the floor put
it on look at yourself go downtown and
wheelie attempt to shoes well thank you
so much for talking to me okay thank you
thanks Mike yeah good luck out there
thanks yeah did I just be 40 bucks you
did you know you mean hide she was gift
card are you please cuz I really don't
wanna go catch those
thank you Mark thank you so much this
opportunity you're really beautiful
actually I think you photographed
beautiful if I've shot before I shot I
shot my Jacob Lawrence you know I don't
feel like I'm very beautiful honestly I
feel like I'm you know you know you know
like you know how people like thinking
and you're like the weird one I mean we
don't like the one little [ __ ] like
giant forehead you okay I feel like
would you want to be when you grow up I
want to be an old son so would an
obsessed with the Olsen twins oh I wish
I can be like them one day they're so
cool there's a coolness ever I love how
they're dressed they're very fashionable